Okay. If someone came to me and said, David,
did you rape this woman? I would say I would
never rape anyone. The characteristics of
the person wouldn't be a factor if they were
attractive.
If they weren't attractive, it wouldn't make
a difference if they were male or female.
It wouldn't make a difference. I just don't
rape anybody. And that would be my focus.
Donald Trump, however, has previously talked
about the attractiveness or the type of woman
when he has denied various rape and sexual
assault allegations. And there are many of
those and he's done it again. Donald Trump
gave an interview to the hill yesterday, including
to cigar and jetty who interviewed me last
week on the hill TV. And Donald Trump has
denied the allegation from aging. Carol saying
she's not my type. With all due respect, uh,
an indication that, uh, as far as Donald Trump
is concerned, this is not an attractive enough
woman for Donald Trump to consider raping.
Uh, take a look at the exact quote from Donald
Trump. I'll say it with great respect. Number
one, she's not my type number two.
It never, it never happened. Okay. Totally
lying. I don't know anything about her. I
know nothing about this woman. I know nothing
about or she is. It's just a terrible thing
that people can make statements like that.
I say this with respect. She's not, my type
is code for, she's not attractive enough for
me to want to sexually assault her or to rape
her, but of course her appearance and her
type should make no difference to someone
who doesn't sexually assault or rape women.
The right answer here is I didn't rape her
because I've never raped anyone and I would
never rape anyone or sexually assault anyone
or use physical force to get anyone in a situation
like the one that is described. If you're
asked if you raped someone and you say, no,
she's not my type that suggests there is a
type you would be willing to rape or sexually
assault.
He's not denying that. If she were his type,
he might have or would have sexually assaulted
her or raped her and remember Trump is accused
of raping his first wife. There are under
oath documents from the divorce proceedings,
I believe it is, or maybe some other kind
of court proceeding about this. Trump also
by saying she's not. My type is continuing
this idea that rape is a sexual act when it's
a very violent act. In reality, it's the exercising
of power over someone else, but that's probably
a few levels too deep for this conversation
or at least any conversation involving Donald
Trump and for everyone talking about another
lying woman lying about Trump raping her or
sexually assaulting her 16 allegations of
sexual assault have not taken Donald Trump
down so far. He even got himself elected after
the grab them by the pussy recording. Would
anyone be dumb enough to think that if they
add their name and make themselves number
17 or number 18 on the list of people that
Donald Trump allegedly sexually assaulted,
would anyone really at this point be dumb
enough to think that that's going to pull
Donald Trump from office?
Which gets us to the idea that these women
are motivated by what? Right? I mean becoming
rich and famous by saying that you were raped
because rape victims end up leading such charmed
lives. She's getting death threats from Trumpists,
which I'll talk about next. Why do you think
so many rapes go unreported? So these ignorant
Trump is to come up with just ridiculous,
bogus defense after ridiculous, bogus defense.
They seem to have no understanding whatsoever
of just basic human psychology and live in
a complete and total bubble about how rape
l a accusers are treated in society. Particularly
when they say that the person that accused
them is a prominent Republican politician.
We've seen that. We've got a number of examples
of how that goes. It doesn't lead to a particularly
thrilling and exciting charmed life. And the
idea that that would be the motivation, uh,
aside from not being based.
In fact, in terms of basic motivations, there's
no drama demonstrable proof that that's actually
how
it works out.